hey everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and I felt compelled to make this video
predicated on the fact that because of
the show that I'm doing right now the
askgaryvee show
d-roc link it up little window yeah so
cool uh I've been getting a question
over and over and over and over again
and even though I've done 123 episodes
of this taste taping taping I like that
recording I haven't really addressed
this on the show because it's such a
crazy crazy question that I want to
address as an individual video and
that's what I'm doing right now the the
question is the following Gary how do I
raise money from an angel investor and
VC and this is happening and this is an
epidemic an epidemic excuse me this is
this a real issue at hand hundreds of
times a day Gary how do I do this Gary
how do I do this and it's literally a
kind of question that really marks the
times where 99% of the entrepreneurs
that I'm interacting with all of their
behaviors predicated on raising the next
round of money versus actually building
a business so very simply my friends I'm
going to answering and very honestly I'm
doing this video for selfish means
because every time I get this question a
thousand a day I'm just going to point
to this video that's one fact I get it
asked so much this may be the most
watched video I have in my career
because so many goddamn people ask this
question and I'm going to give you the
answer the number one way to raise money
from a VC and an angel investor is to
build a good enough business that they
all come to you that's right
here's a novel idea in 2015 why don't
you build a profitable business that
builds real value that has real
customers that pay in whatever form that
means business model whether it's a
freemium or an advertising or you sell
stuff and why don't you build so much
momentum and earned media and hype and
leverage and power and and why don't you
have people actually emailing you asking
you to have a meeting and asking you to
actually take their money begging you to
take not only their money there's smart
money because you're getting the best
angel super angels VC's pounding your
door because you're winning how about
you actually execute and then drive the
behavior backwards
I'm gonna tell you do it and I don't
want to hear like oh like what if you
have no money like you know live a life
that's predicated no money a lot of
people live with no money get seven
friends live in a goddamn studio part
living your mom's basement
find your partner coder build your damn
app and hustle like that's how you raise
money